vote du chômage le terroir la liberté
les impôts l'éducation peut la santé
monter cette envie de commenter si
d'ossau l'intelligence la croissance le
racisme la santé l'homosexualité les
assister vous sentez une rigueur
politique en vous le capitalisme
l'islamisme l'identitarisme l'élitisme
le communautarisme le féminisme à chacun
de ses mots vos muscles se contractent
vos pupilles se dilatent et votre rythme
cardiaque s'accélère
françois fillon emmanuel macron jean luc
mélenchon marine le pen
donald trump ce que j'essaie de vous
faire sentir là c'est ce que le
psychologue jonathan ait appel le
premier principe de la psychologie in
touch and first rizana sagat ou en
français l'intuition d'abord la raison
ensuite ou plus précisément l'intuition
nous forcent une opinion la raison est
ensuite qu'un outil pour donner raison à
notre opinion on parle aussi de
rationalisation des convictions ou
encore d'hooliganisme politique et pour
jonathan wright c'est notre mode de
réflexion par défaut kelly c'est comme
ça que l'on réfléchisse 99 99% du temps
on sait que voter c'est bien et que le
chômage c'est mal et notre raison doit
ensuite nous aider à comprendre pourquoi
en particulier la quasi totalité du
temps
notre raison n'est pas un instrument
pour sonder la vérité pour jonathan
wright nous usons et nous abusons de
raisons pour justifier les positions
idéologiques que l'on a déjà adopté vous
ne me croyez pas qu'on joue l'expérience
l'immigration l'inflation l'insécurité
l'égalité la consommation la france
vous le sentez chacun de ses mots agit
sur nos émotions nous donne envie de
partir dans des envolées lyriques
protestants ou défendant telle ou telle
position idéologique à chacun de ses
mots louis ganne politique en outre épi
est prêt à partir au quart de tour et
c'est ainsi que j'ai eu des douzaines et
des douzaines de discussion ou après
avoir critiqué l'état actuel des
démocraties dans le monde
l'interlocuteur s'interpellent mais
c'est pas ça la démocratie la démocratie
s'est suivie d'une haine que ce 1e
définition de la démocratie que je
n'avais encore jamais entendu jusque là
je peux vous dire que j'en ai entendu
beaucoup des définitions de la
démocratie quand on entend le mot
démocratie notre intuition nous force à
penser qu'il s'agit de quelque chose de
bien et notre raison va ensuite
manipuler la définition du mot pour
justifier notre intuition alors que ce
qui est intéressant ce n'est sans doute
pas la définition du mot démocratie
ce qui est intéressant c'est sans doute
plutôt de penser un système politique
qui je sais pas maximus quelque chose
comme le bien-être et la dignité de ses
citoyens
malheureusement trop souvent on s'arrête
aux émotions que suscitent les mots on
se lance dans des guerres sémantique et
des jeux de connotations tout ça pour
justifier ce que notre intuition nous a
déjà forcé à penser l'intuition d'abord
la raison ensuite eu malheureusement
contrairement à ce que tant d'entre nous
semblons penser il ne s'agit pas là
d'une question d'intelligence ni
d'éducation fait l'éducation semble même
aggraver un peu notre car le psychologue
david perkins il a expérimenté il a posé
des questions de société à des lycéens
des étudiants en licence et des
étudiants en thèse comme est ce qu
augmenter le budget de l'éducation
améliorerait la qualité de
l'enseignement
perkins demande à ses étudiantes d'abord
donner une réponse à ces questions il
leur demanda ensuite décrire tous les
arguments pro est contre sans surprise
les étudiants proposer davantage
d'arguments allant dans le sens de leur
jugement initial
sans surprise non plus les étudiants les
plus éduquées tu es capable d'offrir
davantage d'arguments cependant peur qui
ne trouva aucune différence
significative entre les élèves de
seconde et les terminales
entre les première année d'université
les troisièmes années d'université ou
entre les première année de thèse et les
3e année de thèse
certes les étudiants du supérieur a été
capable de faire plus d'arguments que
les lycéens et les thésards plus que les
étudiants en licence
mais cette différence ne semblait pas
être causée par l'éducation
elle semblait davantage causés par la
sélection seuls les étudiants capables
de penser beaucoup d'arguments avait été
sélectionnée pour continuer leurs études
mais ce n'est pas là la conclusion la
plus stupéfiante de perkins la
conclusion stupéfiante de perkins c'est
que les étudiants les plus prolifiques
était uniquement prolifique pour générer
les arguments allant dans leur sens
les personnes plus éduqués sont en fait
essentiellement celles qui ont été
sélectionnés pour leur capacité à
générer les explications de leur point
de vue les personnes éduquées ne sont
pas celles qui ont convenablement peser
le pour et le contre et essayer de
comprendre tous les tenants et
aboutissants avant de prendre position
les personnes éduquées sont davantage
celles dont la raison excellent pour
trouver des arguments pour défendre une
position
elles sont avant tout deux meilleurs
oligan politique mais qu'on soit sans
diplôme ou qu'on ait une thèse en
mathématiques quand il s'agit de
questions de société l'intuition et
notre dictateur et la raison n'est que
l'avocat de l'intuition l'intuition
d'abord la réunion ensuite
or il est toujours possible de trouver
des raisons pour défendre une intuition
quelle que soit l'imposition si de fait
aux des chiffres semblent contredire une
intuition
il suffit de remettre en question les
motivations ou la naïveté du rapporteur
des faits d'interpréter les chiffres de
la bonne manière et au pire des cas
google nous trois toujours une page web
qui justifiera notre intuition mieux que
notre raison ne le ferais et ce quel que
soit notre intuition de même pire que ça
en s'entourant dolan similaire à nous
ceux qui aujourd'hui inéluctable sur le
web comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode 6 non
seulement notre environnement ne cesse
de conforter notre intuition mais il a
même tendance à toujours plus la
polarisée
jusqu'à la rendre extrême c'est ce que
les scientifiques appellent la
polarisation de groupe fait délibéré des
individus similaires qui ont tendance à
penser que x est plutôt bien et vous
verrez qu'à l'issue de la délibération
les individus seront convaincus que x
est la solution à tous les problèmes par
exemple des études empiriques des jurés
des états unis montrent que la vie des
jurés avant délibération prédit très
bien l'issue de la délibération
jusque là rien de bien étrange mais ce
qui est bizarre c'est que la plupart du
temps si les jurés penche légèrement
vers la clémence avant délibération
alors la délibération conclura à
l'innocence du suspect avec plus de
clémence encore que celle dont chacun
des membres du jury était prêt à faire
preuve avant délibération
al'inverse si les jurés pencher
légèrement vers la culpabilité alors la
délibération conclura à la culpabilité
du suspect avec une sévérité encore plus
grande que celle du juré le plus sévère
avant délibération ce qui se passe en
août c'est qu'une fois que les jurés
penche d'un côté alors ils vont se
mettre à lister plein de raisons de
penser de ce côté et vont ainsi s'auto
convaincre de leur intuition original et
cette auto persuasion et redoutablement
efficace et inconsciente en attestent
les effets de placebo et nocebo
l'intuition d'abord la raison ensuite
pire encore à l'instar des jurés non
seulement parler de politique ne fait
que conforter nos propres intuitions ça
nous amène même à des opinions plus
extrêmes que celles de chacun des
membres du groupe
voilà qui explique pourquoi les
militants politiques sont toujours aussi
sûrs d'eux et qu'il est virtuellement
impossible de les faire changer d'avis
leur intuition tranché et leurs raisons
se sont alliés pour toujours mieux
justifier leur intuition communes et
cantons à faire de telle militants
politiques
on a tellement envie de leur montrer des
faits les chiffres qui contredisent leur
opinion politique mais les faits les
chiffres ne sont quasiment jamais
capable de convaincre l'une des
expériences qui le démontre le mieux est
celle réalisée par dan callikan propose
un exercice de mathématiques ultra
classique où il fallait utiliser une
règle de trois pour déterminer
l'efficacité d'une crème plutôt de
réussite à l'exercice fut décevant à mon
sens mais il ne fut pas catastrophique
kahane modifié ensuite uniquement
l'emballage de l'exercice
remplaçants la crème par une loi sur
l'interdiction des armes qui outre
atlantique est un débat de société
extrêmement clivant et au sujet duquel
tout américain un avis tranché
devinez quoi quand bien même l'exercice
était présenté comme un exercice de
mathématiques
le taux de réussite chuté drastiquement
lorsque la conclusion attendue allait à
l'encontre des convictions de la
personne examiner pire encore chaque
examiné concluent que les chiffres
confirment et ses convictions
quels que soient les chiffres et quelles
que soient les convictions de l'examiner
encore pire encore meilleur l'examiner
camatte plus sa conclusion finale était
biaisé la conclusion de cette étude est
absolument désastreuse
elle montre que plus on raisonne sur des
faits des chiffres plus on trouve deux
raisons de conforter notre intuition et
ce même si ces faits ces chiffres sont
en fait en train de contredire nos
intuitions
pire encore tout ça semble d'autant plus
vrai que l'on met à l'aise avec les
faits et les chiffres de même des études
montrent que la lecture d'un article sur
la peine de mort exacerbe les opinions
des lecteurs qu'ils soient pour ou
contre la peine de mort ce n'est donc
sans doute pas en faisant appel à la
raison et au fait que vous convaincre et
les autres il y à même de bonnes chances
que l'appel à la raison et au fait
empire votre cas parce que
l'interlocuteur fera alors immédiatement
de sa raison l'avocat dévoué à son
intuition
d'ailleurs contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire intuitivement ce sont
les personnes éduquées qui croît le plus
ou paranormal c'est en tout cas ce
qu'affirme henry broc sur la tronche en
deux le niveau de croyances au
paranormal augmente proportionnellement
au niveau d'études
j'ai pas dis inversement accor
proportionnellement au niveau de jouer
au plus haut niveau d'études est élevé
au plus niveau de croyances au
paranormal élevé malheureusement bien
souvent lorsque notre intuition
prédomine
plus on s'informe plus on trouve de
bonnes raisons de croire ce que l'on
croit peu importe l'information que l'on
lit l'engagement politique ne fait que
renforcer l'hooliganisme politique
cette observation a même été confirmée
dans le domaine des sciences par la
thèse de doctorat de derek miller le
présentateur de la chaîne veritas y
sommes derek a montré à des étudiants
des vidéos expliquant un principe
physique contre intuitif comme le fait
qu'une balle subi une force de gravité
constante les étudiants dire avoir
trouvé les vidéos très clair cependant
rares étaient les étudiants qui remis en
cause leur intuition 0 n'est pire encore
les vidéos pourtant parfaitement
justifiée et bien expliqué augmenter
même la confiance des étudiants en leur
interprétation erronée
autrement dit les vidéos scientifiques
bien expliqué renforce ce qui est
regarde dans leurs convictions non
scientifique tout enseignant pédagogue
éducateurs vulgarisateur ou communicants
doit absolument prendre note des
trouvailles contre intuitive de derek
expliquer de manière parfaitement juste
et avec des faits bien documenté ne
suffit pas pire encore c'est
l'explication ne remet jamais en cause
explicitement l'intuition de
l'interlocuteur la vidéo peut avoir un
impact pédagogique nuisibles si ça c'est
vrai pour des faits des théories
scientifiques bien établie dans un
contexte scolaire
je vais à s'imaginer ce que ça peut
donner en politique le philosophe sean
brennan la firme sèchement la politique
abruti et qu'on les sciences
expérimentales du confirme encore et
encore plus au s'intéresse à la
politique avec un parti pris plus notre
penchant initial se transforme en
hooliganisme politiques radicales il
vous dit tout ça ce n'est pas pour que
vous changez d'avis au moment d'aller
voter dimanche
la pression c'est expérimental j'ai pas
réussi à vous faire changer d'avis
d'ailleurs au moment où j'écris ce
script je sais même pas qui est au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
si je vous raconte tout ça c'est pour
que vous ayez un moment d'hésitation au
moment d'aller ou de ne pas aller voter
dimanche
avez-vous vraiment bien lu tous les
programmes des candidats sans
hooliganisme politique
et avez vous croisé ses programmes avec
les recherches en économie
sociologie sans lesquelles il sera a
priori impossible d'anticiper les
conséquences des réformes proposées par
les différents candidats
n'auriez-vous pas juste suivi votre
intuition et vos émotions que votre
raison aurait ensuite conforté avec les
arguments haddock dimanche au moment du
vote posez vous la question êtes vous
vraiment sûr de faire ce qui est bien
pour la france où ne faites-vous
qu'écouter et conforter le week-end
politique qui sommeille en vous la 1ère
fois
edit d'ailleurs le veut et pas les
joueurs avec une vision assez mécanique
des choses par exemple notamment les
aspects psychologiques des différents
acteurs du jeu sont un petit peu ignorée
et bob l'eponge nous fait du coup cette
critique qui donne l'impression que le
modèle la théorie des jeux ignore
complètement plein d'aspects des
sciences du maine qui sont pourtant très
importants comme on l'a vu d'ailleurs
dans l'épisode que vous venez de voir
des faits en général la théorie des jeux
en ligne aurait plein de choses de la
psychologie notamment les biais
cognitifs et tout ça mais ce que je cite
d'arguer sais que c'est pas forcément
après que ça peut être un problème dans
certaines applications
mais dans d'autres applications ça peut
ne pas être un problème parce que les
incitatifs sont tellement forts que les
joueurs sont indiscernables de six à dix
c'est uniquement en fonction des
incitatifs qui avait pas trop d'aspects
psychologique derrière tout ça tel que
je vois ça c'est quand même très
similaire au fait que par exemple les
biologistes n'utilise pas de modèle de
théorie quantique des champs pour
justifier la division cellulaire ou que
sais-je encore et de la même façon et
psychologues n'utilise pas les principes
de diffusion cellulaire ou les gènes
pour expliquer les comportements des
individus dans tous ces cas là en fait
on a une description macroscopique qui
ignorent certains effets microscopique
parce que ses effets microscopiques
ils sont pas forcément si pertinent à
l'analyse macroscopique mais surtout si
on essayé d'inclure ces effets
microscopiques à l'échelle macroscopique
on obtiendra des modèles qui sont
impossibles à étudier et qui ne seraient
incapables de faire des prédictions
ça rejoint encore une fois la citation
de josh fox tous les modèles sont faux
mais certains sont utiles et je pense
que c'est vraiment le cas à toutes les
échelles double par le niveau de la
biologie au niveau des psychologies et
encore plus au niveau de la théorie des
jeux où je pense qu'on peut dire que
c'est une théorie qui est encore plus
macroscopique donc beaucoup moins
précises et a fortiori beaucoup plus
fausse que les théories
en dessous alors du coup est ce que
cette théorie des jeux fait vraiment
partie des sciences non j'aime pas ce
genre de débat parce que je faut que le
fou science est tellement mal défini et
de base je suis pas très attaché à la
notion de la méthode scientifique je
vois l'occasion de revenir sur pas mal
de choses comme ça on a beau vous avez
fait cette présentation que je critique
pas mal la méthode scientifique donc
vous invite à aller voir cette vidéo et
je compte bien réaborder est sous un
format ou un autre ces questions de
dépister tôt toujours est il que
certains appellent l'étude de la
politique sans opinion politique
les séances politique et je trouve que
c'est un nom qui est pas du tout usurpé
à montceau des scènes torrides nous
faire la remarque que certaines règles
sont immuables alors que d'autres ne
saoule pas je pense que c'est pas tout à
fait vrai je pense que les règles sont
toujours plus ou moins durable peut
toujours changer un peu les règles
puisque les règles sont des fabrications
humaine en général donc peut-être qu'à
les lois de la physique
on peut pas changer mais dans la vie
quotidienne les eaux à la physique
importait peu et ce qui m'a intéressé
c'est plus les bois d'interaction entre
les humains et ses lois d'interaction
humaine
elles ont énormément évolué si on
regarde l'histoire de l'humanité par
exemple la démocratie c'est finalement
c'est très très très jeune dans
l'histoire de l'humanité et ses règles
évoluent au fur et à mesure on peut les
affecter
sauf que bien sûr comme sébastien dufour
le fait remarquer ce qu'ils sont
capables de changer les règles du jeu et
son sous sol sont en général ceux qui
ont le pouvoir en général de change et
plein de choses ça veut pas dire que on
est incapables nous chacun d'entre nous
à notre échelle d'influencer les règles
du jeu dans le futur en fait le vote en
démocratie est justement une façon de
donner un indirectement du pouvoir au
peuple puisque à ce moment là les
employés qui ont quand même pas mal
intérêt à faire ce que le peuple veut
qu'ils fassent si ces hommes politiques
veulent être et rester au pouvoir sauf
si bien sûr il s'agit de règles
qui sont obscures que le peuple connaît
mal ou que le sur lesquels le peuple n'a
pas vraiment dit son opinion et c'est le
cas sur pas mal de questions en fait en
politique et là je vous invite encore
une fois énormément avoir cette superbe
vidéo de cgpi greenwich foi ou leur zh
oui notamment il ya une partie de la
vidéo où il parle de la manière dont les
hommes politiques ont manipulé le jeu de
la politique notamment en démocratie
pour pouvoir leur garantir plus de
pouvoir plus facilement donc typiquement
il ya le djoliba en anglais c'est à dire
le découpage en zones électorales pour
avoir des représentants le en fait la
manière dont les zones électorales ont
été coupées ont été en fait décidé par
des hommes pouvoir par les politiciens
et ils ont souvent choisi ces découpages
de sorte à garantir qu'ils puissent être
et rester au pouvoir aussi longtemps que
possible
ananda nous demande si au final ce sont
les hommes politiques ou les convictions
qui cherche à être resté au pouvoir
en fait je pense que c'est les deux tout
simplement chacun joue son jeu à son
échelle et en fait je dirais même que un
homme politique puissant c'est quelqu'un
qui arrive à avoir une certaine symbiose
avec les bonnes convictions les plus
viral du monde comme le fait remarquer
science clic dans les deux cas on a une
compétition entre différents individus
conviction et il ya un processus de
sélection c'est à dire que les individus
qui sont pas assez prolifique qui sont
pas assez contagieux vont finir par
disparaître et restera plus que les
hommes politiques et les convictions
plus le vire au sage populaire babin
boli demande aussi à pas quand même un
problème avec la théorie de mesquita
dans ce sens où les hommes politiques
sion cette théorie ne font jamais
d'erreur faute c'est pas tout à fait
vrai français pensent qu'on entend par
erreur qu'en effet les hommes politiques
vont toujours faire ce qu'il ya de mieux
selon pour eux mais ils vont faire ça en
fonction de leur compréhension du monde
de qui les entoure il peut avoir une
information c'est un complexe c'est à
dire ils peuvent très bien ne pas savoir
ce qu'un autre fait ce qu'un autre veut
à ce moment là les hommes politiques
sont obligés d'agir selon leur
compréhension du monde
si cette incompréhension et erronées ou
incomplètes choisiront alors des actions
qui selon eux au moment où ils ont pris
la décision semblait être la meilleure
décision étant donné leurs informations
limitées notamment mais a posteriori on
pourrait comprendre trempette il
s'agissait de la mauvaise décision parce
que je n'avais pas toutes les bonnes
informations qu'il fallait pour prendre
la décision
en fait ce manque d'information cette
information incomplète c'est un
ingrédient extrêmement important de la
théorie des jeux qui fait que les gens
peuvent prendre les décisions qui a
posteriori sans parfum est mauvaise tu
kia nous demandent de malgré tout
condamné les joueurs qui se comportent
de manière immorale et en fait c'est ce
qui me remplace un suarez a pris un
carton rouge
ouais à dire que c'est pas une punition
suffisamment grande puisque toi sont si
nombreux et se faire éliminer mais lisez
plus généralement des punitions c'est
exactement ça l'idée de mettre en place
une punition c'est de donner des
incentives aux gens ne pas agir de façon
in our had ce qui s'est passé dans
lequel de suarez c'est qu'en fait un
carton rouge la 120e minute ça vaut pas
grand chose c'est pas le même carton
rouge qu'un carton rouge à la 10e minute
de jeu
foot de la france que c'est vraiment un
truc qu'il faudra méditer au foot je
pense que c'est un vrai problème que le
carton rouge soit donné pour les mêmes
raisons à la 10e et la 120e minute alors
que c'est pas du tout la même punition à
10 minutes et à ce contenu et ça c'est
un vrai poème parce que c'est un
problème d'inadéquation de la punition
en termes d incentive ça donne pas assez
les bons incentives aux joueurs de ne
pas faire ce qu'on ne veut pas qu'il
fasse plus généralement dans nos
sociétés on a mis en place des punitions
des l'emprisonnement notamment pour les
gens qui font des actes que l'on
considère immoraux tout ça pour donner
les incentives aux gens de ne pas faire
des choses immorales
alors bien sûr la loi est ce qu'elle est
ils sont très imparfaite ce qui fait que
l'on n'a pas toujours les bons
incentives pour empêcher les gens de la
gère de façon immorale
parfois c'est même pas clair que l'on
puisse construire un système
l'initiative qui permettent de garantir
cela t'a moi parce que on n'est pas
capable de juger et culpabilité de telle
ou telle personne est en tout cas à
défaut d'avoir des règles dans le jeu
qui punissent les comportements immoraux
il ya aussi un facteur psychologique les
humains qui est le fait que en général
les gens n'aiment pas être stigmatisés
et du coup il ya une punition
psychologique au fait d'agir de façon
immorale lors donc si tout le peuple se
mettaient à condamner moralement une
personne si cette personne a certain
sentiment d'empathie
il s'agirait d'une énorme punition
psychologique que de devoir subir cette
condamnation morale du peuple donc cette
condamnation morale elle a quand même un
point important à jouer dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui puisqu'elles permettent de
donner des incentives aux gens se
comportaient de ne sorte à éviter ce
genre de jugement moral sévère mais même
dans ce cas là vous voyez que en tant
que théoricien des jeux ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont les incentives et
donc s'il ya des incentives e pour les
dirigeantes à se comporter de façon
immorale parce que ils risquent ensuite
d'avoir un public chez mine qui va
conduire au licenciement là à ce moment
là ce public shiming entre dans le jeu
et fait partie du jeu et donc même là le
focus à mon sens doit être sur le jeu
pas les joueurs d'ailleurs comme le fait
remarquer paule amblard la notion
d'autriche de jouer le jeu est une
notion tous assez subjective c'est
souvent une construction sociale des
règles souvent assez implicite mais qui
sont quand même présents et j'aime bien
l'analogie avec les jeux vidéo si un bug
dans un jeu est-ce qu'on exploite le bug
ou est ce qu'on essaie de jouer à la
loyale me rajeunir mais je sais qu'il ya
un ss sur super nintendo
lorsque l'on tirait un certain endroit
assez loin du but
à chaque fois ça faisait but du coup bas
avec une couse ans elie baup a qu'à dire
qu'on n'a pas le droit de faire ça ne
pas le tiers restant droit là pour jouer
le jeu j'espère que vous allez aimer
cette vidéo la pression va rester un
petit peu dans ces notions
psychologie et de la manière dont
comment les électeurs pensent et en
particulier on va même justifié
l'irrationalité des électeurs encore une
fois la prochaine vidéo ne sera pas une
réaction
le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle puisqu'il aura été déjà
écrit et au clos des mêmes avant le
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à la
callas commentaire partagé pense à vous
abonner pour doter le futur vidéo merci
aussi peur pour leurs dons et j'espère
que vous serez là la prochaine fois
les neurologues ont montré que notre
hémisphère gauche souvent considéré
comme le ciel de la raison est en
réalité le siège de la rationalisation
son job est de maintenir la cohésion de
notre vision du monde quitte à tordre un
peu l'effet pour le faire rentrer dans
des cases déjà dessiné exposé
[Musique]